(bells twinkling)
(wind rushing)
- [Announcer] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us
on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to our
conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Mary Ann Mason
who is a professor and co-director
of the Center for Economics
and Family Security
at the University of California
Berkeley School of Law.
Her most recent book
co-authored with her daughter
Eve Mason Ekman is
Mothers on the Fast Track:
How a New Generation Can
Balance Family and Careers.
Mary Ann, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you Harry. (laughs)
- [Harry] Well you're
already at Berkeley, sorry.
Welcome to the program.
- Nice to be here in this room.
- Thank you, welcome to our program.
Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Minnesota,
Hibbing, Minnesota.
Bob Dylan country.
One of the coldest places
in the world. (laughs)
And then we moved quite a lot.
Went to college and graduate
school on the east coast
and then came to California
where I've been happily here
for more than 40 years.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Ah, that's a good question.
My father's an immigration officer.
They were not intellectuals.
They were very good, decent people.
I think they shaped it in
part because we moved so often
that we were always new places,
moving, seeing new things.
And as an only child I spent a lot of time
observing what I was seeing.
So in some ways it was
a very good preparation
for anyone to be a student of the world.
- And so in traveling did you
met a lot of different people
at a very young age and
different sets of friends?
- Yes, very much.
I think the most memorable
probably was a convent school
in Winnipeg, Canada, very strict
where the nuns were very strict
mainly boarding students and
some commuters like myself
and it was always dark in Winnipeg
'cause it's so far north, so I'd start out
with my three buses at
seven in the morning
and then I'd take the three
buses home in the dark
in the dark and it was in
many ways a bleak time,
but I made such good friendships
and I got to really admire the teachers.
I saw a whole different culture, in a way,
that I wouldn't have if
I'd been in a regular,
fun high school and having
a good time. (laughs)
- Was there discussion
around the dinner table
about world issues and
also women's issues?
When did that first
enter your consciousness?
- Not around my kitchen table.
Most of the discussion
was what did you have
for lunch today, and I think
the basement needs fixing
or something of that nature.
Very good people, but as I
say, it wasn't very worldly
inside the house, very supportive.
- And any teachers along this--
- Yes.
- Circuitous route.
- Yes, in terms of the
women's movement, I mean,
I graduated from Vassar in 1965,
which is really just on the cusp.
When I was a senior in college I remember
I was reading both Bride Magazine
'cause maybe like half of my classmates
was going to get married
right away on graduation
and I also picked up Betty
Friedan's The Feminine Mystique.
It was just amazing the juxtaposition
and it really was that time in history.
I had one professor at
Vassar, Carl Degler,
a wonderful historian and a great mentor
and I did my thesis with him
and he was very encouraging.
He said you must go to graduate
school, you must get a PhD.
And they were very good at Vassar
because they encouraged women to do things
that wasn't so common at that time.
If I'd been at another school
I would not have gotten
that encouragement.
And I said, "Well thank
you Professor Degler,
"but I'm sorry, I'm getting
married this summer.
"I'll go back to school sometime perhaps,
"but I have to go where my husband is."
And he asked me where my fiance was.
And he said, "Oh, well,
"they have a wonderful history department.
"You can go there and I'm
sure you can get a fellowship,
"a national fellowship,
why don't you apply for it?
"I'll help you."
"Oh, thank you Professor Degler."
And then he actually, he didn't stalk me,
but every time he saw me on
campus he'd come over and say,
"Miss Mason, have you
applied yet, Miss Mason?"
"Oh Professor Degler, I'm
getting around to it."
So finally I applied and I got it
and so I started a PhD program
where my first husband was
getting his PhD and I knew we'd be there
just for a short time,
but because I'd started
and really loved it I continued
when we moved out to Berkeley.
And he made all the difference.
- And what drew you to history?
- Well I was a history
major as an undergraduate
and it was, now that I think about it,
it was kind of like my
early days of traveling.
It was seeing the world
from different perspectives.
It was just to me opening up all,
more interesting than novels
'cause it was whole civilizations
and whole governments
and just all of world's
knowledge was there.
And then I loved, loved, loved,
those were the days when
you spent time in the stacks
just with your nose in the primary sources
reading letters from
the French Revolution.
Just very exciting.
- And so talk now, let's relate this
to your emerging consciousness
about women's issues.
You mention reading Betty
Friedan as an undergraduate.
So I get the sense in reading about you
that the life you were living
and the movement around you,
the women's movement
really opened up your,
so there was an interaction there
between the life you were living
and what the women movement was saying.
- Right, I came out to Berkeley in 1967
and that will raise anyone's
consciousness about everything.
It was the days of the
riots and the free speech
and the anti-Vietnam, is
was really quite thrilling
and all your suppositions
and understandings
of everything are just up for grabs.
So it was very active,
and the women's movement
was very nascent then, this
was just the end of the '60s.
It started to grow and I joined
the consciousness raising
movement like many women.
And then we started, I was teaching
while I was a graduate
student at a small college,
Holy Names College in Oakland
and we got together all
the women in California
who were teaching history
at four-year colleges
and there were eight of us.
It was really a very tiny band
and a lot of closed doors.
Only 1.3 women historians
in all the UC campuses,
in all nine UC campuses.
So I think that raised my consciousness
more than anything else to know
that it still was such a closed door.
That there was a lot of
talk, but very little action
in terms of opening the doors.
When I finally got to Berkeley
as a professor in 1989
things had changed dramatically
and I think at that time about
15% of the faculty were women
but it was only 2% of
all the faculty in 1972.
So it was a huge shift
during that period of time.
- As a historian, what was your focus
and how did that focus change over time?
- Yes, it was American labor history,
which is part of American social history.
So in some ways it really
didn't change over time.
It's always looking at the
masses rather than the classes
and what they're doing
and what's happening.
And I did my dissertation
in The Bancroft Library
on a California labor
leader and I loved it.
I loved every minute
of being on this campus
during my dissertation.
I didn't get back for many years,
but I really loved being here at the time.
Like graduate students,
these were the best years
of my life. (laughs)
- At a certain point you decide
that you want to move beyond history
and undertake a law degree.
- Well, I don't know that people's lives,
certainly women's lives
are not that, I think,
clearly guided from within.
What happened is a small
college that I was teaching at,
they didn't go coed, but Saint Mary's,
which was the men's college.
A similar thing happened in the east coast
when men's colleges went coed
and a lot of the women's
colleges lost their,
basically lost their students.
So they let go all of
their lay faculty one year
and I had just actually
had a child by this time.
He was just a year and a half, I think.
And I just didn't want
to be a gypsy scholar
or a sort of, I just didn't know.
So I went to law school
just because I didn't know.
And I continued to teach history
while I was in law school actually.
So I actually went over three
years, three and a half years
and was always teaching history
first at San Francisco
State and then actually
full time at Saint Mary's.
Again, looking back you
make patterns of your life
retrospectively I think
rather than the time
you just sort of move with the flow.
But I did like law a lot, it
was very interesting to me
and still is.
- And several of your books
are actually on family law
and divorce and the rights
of children and so on.
- Yes, rights of children
and child custody
are my specialties, and step
parents to some extent as well.
So I did spend many
years teaching children
and the law and family
law, juvenile court law.
- And how do you account
for this particular focus,
or do you?
- Ah, that's a good question.
Yes, actually I know exactly why I did.
I wrote a book in 1989
called The Equality Trap
which was about basically
opening up the doors to women
but not leveling the playing field
so that you're kind of
setting women up for failure.
And women themselves at that time
did not want to be accommodationist.
So they were not asking for
any kind of mommy tract.
Paid leave or flexible time,
this was considered to be,
in fact my book was
considered to be a little bit
of a traitor to the movement
'cause I was talking
about accommodations, and then I realized
when I came to Berkeley that
the way that you can do that
is actually through children.
You can think about women's
issues through children
and get a lot of the
same structural changes
that you might have if you
had just focused on women.
And at that time, to be honest, I suppose
I was playing it a little
more safe than perhaps,
just in the sense that
being a feminist anything
was not necessarily a popular thing
in terms of getting
tenure at Berkeley then.
But more than that, I really
was interested in children,
who were very, very understudied.
Even now, there are so
few books about children
and children's history
and children's culture.
We've actually started,
Paula Fass here on campus
has really begun this
movement and many of us
are doing the history of
childhood in various ways.
- It's interesting
because it is very clear
that central to your work is
kind of a focus on the family.
- Yes.
- And you just suggested
that in a way that the
early feminists my have been
overly dismissive of the
family in their efforts
to get liberation and equality for women.
Is that a fair assessment?
- Well, yes.
I mean I think it's an
understandable assessment
because women have always
been so closely stereotyped
and caught in the family
that there was no opportunity
for them to change or grow,
so I certainly understand
why there was a rejection of the family.
In fact in my years when
my children were born
it was kind of the don't
ask don't tell years.
You didn't bring them to school.
You didn't even tell your professors
or the professors, I remember
when my son was born,
I think I was finishing
my PhD and professors
kind of looked at your pregnant self
and never mentioned it
and you didn't mention it
and that was the way it was.
So it wasn't considered an advantage
and it was considered something
that was your own problem.
It was not a social or
a workplace problem.
- You probably have thought a lot about
how the women's movement
have had to evolve.
And I assume you bring a
kind of a sense of history
and a historian's way of looking at that.
Talk a little about that evolution
where as we do this
interview we're celebrating
the anniversary of Betty Friedan's books.
So there's a lot in the
press and this new book
by the CEO of Facebook Sheryl
Sandberg on leaning in.
So reflect a little on what you've seen
of the women's movement and how
it's impacted you and so on.
- Of course when I think
of the women's movement
as a historian I think of 1848
and Seneca Falls Convention,
the first women's rights convention
and the suffragettes and
mainly in those first years
women tried so hard to get
just very basic rights.
And those rights were really
voting rights, not so much,
and to some extent divorce,
but the women's movement
actually was always very
mixed on the divorce issues.
But the current women's
movement has really been focused
on economic gain and in
entry into the workplace.
And it's really not coincidental
that it's the same time
that the family wage is no longer possible
and can't support women and children.
My father did on an
immigration officer's salary
and bought a car and a little
house, but not possible today.
So the workplace opened
up not because the women
banged on the door, it opened
up because the economy shifted
and we needed two incomes to do it.
But it also opened up for
women going into professions
and fields that had been
very dominated by men.
So that's the thrust of this
current women's movement,
which was not the case for
the older women's movements.
And because the thrust was
to get into the economic structure
I think the first wave felt strongly
that they had to do it on men's terms.
It was the only way they're
going to be able to make it.
And to some extent there's
still a truth to that,
a strong truth to that.
So there was really a fear of recognition
that there would be
anything holding them back
or anything that would possibly
tie them still to the family
either psychologically or
structurally or whatever.
And that really began to change happily.
As I said, I wrote this book in 1989
that talked about accommodation
in the workplace, nyet.
And then in 2000 when I started
working on this issue again
as graduate dean I was
really pleased to hear
that it was a welcome
voice, my voice was welcome
and people were looking at
structure, structural change
and not just on doing it like the men.
Children and families had
been noticed in the meantime.
And that was very good,
although I have to say
the younger generation, my
daughter and her friends
never knew that there'd be any problem
because they assumed that,
although they had no children
and had no family,
because they were raised
in such an egalitarian
atmosphere they didn't recognize
that they might run into bumps at all.
So I asked her to write the book with me
so she could interview a lot of the women
like Dianne Feinstein,
women who had been there
and done that with families.
It was a very, very
strong experience for her.
- You're suggesting in your work and now
that really both the
family and women's issues
sort of feel the pressures
of the changes in society
both internationally and nationally.
So globalization enters
into this discussion.
Inequality enters into this discussion.
And also the divisions
within the women's movement,
namely working class
women who have to work
versus professional women
who, say, can hire a nanny
to do some of the functions at home.
- In The Equality Trap I called
it women who worked to live
and women who lived to
work and to some extent
that division was even clearer then
than it is now I think
because the first group
of feminists who got into
professional organizations
were very, very strong and
organized and brought suits
and they opened the doors.
And the second group now, I think,
is wondering why it all didn't
turn out like they wanted.
Like Anne-Marie Slaughter's
book on how hard it is
you can't have it all, et cetera.
I think this is very good that
this debate is raised again
because I think it was quiet for a while
and now they're raising it
with kind of different stakes
but a lot of the same old arguments.
- Do you think there's
a better conversation
within the women's movement
between the different classes
within the women's movement so that
professional wealthy women
can understand the situation
of working-class women
who really have to work?
- No, and I think that's
never been the strength
of the women's movement.
It's always been very
articulate, well-educated,
professional or at least
certainly college-educated women.
Often authors or journalists, et cetera
who have run the conversation.
Not much attention to the most women
who are the low-income
workers and have to work.
The only thing I can say about that,
which is kind of interesting.
In the last 30 years,
the great time divide
that women who are lower income
actually are working
fewer hours partly 'cause
they don't have enough hours.
They're working hourly rates often.
And women who are
professionals have shut up
in terms of the number of
hours that they're working,
many more hours than the women
who are more low-income jobs.
So we're essentially
working harder all the time
if you actually shattered
that ceiling anyway
or got even into any kind of profession.
- So you are a lawyer, you are a historian
and then you become
university administrator.
- Yes.
- And so talk a little
about that before we
get into one of the way
you try to address the women's
issue as a graduate dean.
What's the difference
in the skills required
for each of these professions?
- Well, they are different skill
sets, no question about it.
I mean, this university
system has a tradition
of taking people from the faculty.
And the strong part about that
is that you're on the side of the faculty,
although people say you've
gone to the dark side
and you understand the
inherent problems with faculty.
You understand the structure
of the university, probably.
But many people who are
pointed at these jobs
with these huge budgets,
they have never looked
at an accounting sheet or
have much sense of that
or have worked with personnel before.
And any kind of manager,
those are the two big things.
The budget and the personnel.
So that is kind of a steep curve for many.
Actually I had some administrative jobs
when I was a lawyer, so
I had a little experience
on a smaller scale.
Berkeley has as you know more
graduate students than anybody
so it's a much larger
scale in terms of budget
and personnel, but also the good part
about large institutions
like this you just say, well,
send it to legal, to some extent.
You have to manage it, but
you have a lot of people
to help you as well, and very talented
mid-level administrators
at this university.
The reason I wanted, well
actually I was kind of surprised
that they wanted me to be, and honestly
I'd been active on the campus
and I was acting associate dean
for a period of time and I enjoyed it.
The thing I liked most
about it both in terms
of faculty-centered kinds of service
and also being the associate
dean is that you get to see
the wide breadth of this
incredible university.
Most of us are just
stuck in our departments
and you just see the same
limited number of people,
but this is such an
incredibly fabulous place.
105 graduate programs.
I always said, I could
recognize the name if I saw it,
but I couldn't rattle
it off, there's so many.
And each of them has got
just a wealth of information,
brilliance, discovery, innovation
and it's just breathtaking,
that was the most wonderful part
about being dean to be able to all of it,
the whole scope of it.
- So in this new position,
how did you come to identify
the problem of women, their
careers, and the university?
Was this just a natural
choice given your background?
- Well, it was a natural choice.
It was made a lot easier
because when I first arrived
there was a small research unit
that had been put in
place by my predecessor
Mark Golden, who's been
my partner in research
all these years was a staff person
and he came to me and he said,
"I know you're interested
in family issues."
I guess he knew something
about my background.
He said, "We have this great database
"and it's got all the PhDs
that ever got their PhDs
"since 1973 and it's longitudinal.
"They follow them through
every two years, 10%.
"I can ask questions
for you like I can say,
"look at your graduate students now.
"Who is going to fall out,
who's going to stay in?
"What affect does family
formation have on them?"
I was thrilled because this
is the kind of information
that I knew could really
make a difference.
I mean, data speak.
If you've got numbers and you've got,
I knew that much about the university.
The only things that change things
are when you've got a lot of evidence
to show why it needs changing.
And he's a great researcher
and we started out
and did the research, started
with just a baseline survey
of all the UC faculty on family issues.
How many children do they
have, what concerns they had,
had they ever used any
policies, et cetera.
And that was a real catalyst,
'cause then we had some real information,
and then we started
crunching some of the numbers
with this survey of doctor recipient.
And the Sloan Foundation found me.
And literally this is what
the Sloan Foundation did
in those days, if they found someone
who they thought was doing
really interesting work
in the area, in this case, was work family
they just supported you, so
they supported us for 10 years.
And that allowed us to add,
actually just maybe one more person.
It almost a small staff and
to sort of thing big visions
about what we could do
next, so it was a wonderful,
thrilling time because
we produced the data.
We did the UC faculty, we did
all the doctoral students.
We did all the postdocs in the systems
and we had these huge
samples that nobody ever had.
You could really say
something pretty strong
about how graduate students
felt about the university.
Did they think it was family friendly?
What were their plans?
And you could get an enormous
amount of information
just by asking people.
Surveys are not easy to do
because no one likes to answer them.
So we had to rely on the
president of the university
and the chancellors to
really kind of push people
along to do it, but they were
willing, they were willing.
So we had a really good
timing and set of issues
that was critical, clearly,
to a lot of people.
And producing all the data that we did
at a time when nobody else
had data was very timely.
- And were the right
questions already being asked,
or did you have to come in and say,
well what about this and what about that?
So what was the degree of addition
that you were bringing to the table
in addition to identifying
what could be done here
because of your knowledge of the problems?
- Well we did, we created the survey
so you could ask all the
questions you thought
would be relevant and we
tried to do some carry-through
questions between the
faculty and the postdocs
and the graduate students
like, how busy is everybody?
Looking at a household for a particular,
if you have a child and
they're mother and the father,
who works the most hours?
And you saw a distinct and
almost identical second shift
for mothers between the
faculty and graduate students
and the postdocs who had
children in the home.
And a huge second shift,
an additional 20 hours
to what the fathers were
doing and 30 hours over
or 40 hours over what
everyone else was doing.
When you see it like that
and you see 'em identical,
you know this is not
just a generational issue
that things are still pretty
much the way they were.
That particular finding and
the slide that we had with it
I think was one of the most
eye-opening for everyone
to know that it's still
largely a mother's problem
and that is an issue.
That was one of the ground-breakers.
So we knew the questions and then in terms
of what policies to do, really fortunate
there were people in the
office of the president
who had some ideas.
A lot of people have good ideas
and although this system is
large and sometimes ungainly
it's very centralized, so
when you're doing anything
like personnel policy or
leaves or maternity benefits
all the campuses do it all together.
So we could do UC-wide
family friendly policies
in one fell scoop. (laughs)
- Now I wanna break this down
and walk you through the data
in a minute, but I think
a very important point
that you make in summarizing a lot of this
in one of the papers that I read
is that previously most
of the focus had been
on ensuring women's equality
by looking at representation,
you know, and salary.
- Yes.
- But what was being
added now to the equation
was measuring also what
was happening to the family
who was assuming the burden of
responsibility in the family
and what were the costs of that for women
in their efforts to be equal in society?
- We were adding that, we
were adding another thing
'cause we stood the basic question.
What is the effect of family formation
on the career lives of men and women
on its head and asked what is the effect
of careers on family and here we showed
even a greater discrepancy
than who gets to be a tenured faculty
in terms of those people
who are tenured faculty,
who has children and a
marriage and who doesn't.
Huge gap, I think it's 42%
for tenured faculty women
versus 75% for tenured faculty men.
So you have a gap in both ways,
kind of a double gap there.
There are fewer women at the top
and those that are have fewer families,
fewer children and are
less likely to be married.
So it's kind of a double whammy.
I call it double trouble
for gender equity. (laughs)
And then we also did find the discrepancy
in the hours of work, as you say.
- Right, so
in this data, were you surprised
by some of the findings
or did it just confirm what
you had already thought?
- What I was really surprised at
is that most of the
leak out of the pipeline
both men and women likely leave,
but more woman than men actually occurred,
well after they got their PhD,
but they changed their mind
during the graduate school years
and during the postdoc years.
They make up their mind, they
changed their career goals
away from their original choice
and are more likely to drop out,
highly more likely to drop
out of they have children.
Like with postdocs, a
woman who has a child
while they're a postdoc is 41% say
they're no longer going
to pursue their career.
Just too damn hard.
Whereas the fathers, only
20% change their mind
and single women, 19%,
so you have a huge gap.
And the graduate students
as well, a huge gap
from the beginning when they
enter their graduate program
to two or three years later
they have already changed
their minds because they see
the faculty more differently.
They don't have that many women models.
If they have a child they'll
definitely, or not definitely,
but far more likely not to go on.
So you see that the impact of policies
is not just on faculty where
there had been some attention,
but also on the graduate
students and the postdocs.
So I put a lot of attention
with those two groups as well
to try to keep the pipeline going.
- At the heart of all of this seems to be
questions about woman's role in the family
and whether women, and
I gotta be careful here,
I say this, but that women are different
and we should embrace that
in the sense that they...
Well no, I don't think I want
to say what I was just gonna.
What I wanna say is that
the default position
is that women are the
custodians of the family
in a way that men had not
been, but the structures
if changed might change that relationship.
- Right, and one of the major focuses
on changing the structure
was to get fathers to participate more.
And I have to say, we've been
quite successful at that.
In 1980, I think it was President Gardner
had actually put in
place for the UC system
some family-friendly policies
like stopping the clock
and a semester off of
teaching for childbirth
that had been in place.
They were incredibly far-sighted
and progressive at the time.
By the time we did our survey in 2002,
most people didn't even know they existed.
It had fallen totally out of favor
and the women sometimes used 'em,
but fathers never used them
even though they had access
to stop the clock and some
childbirth leave as well.
So the new policies we put in place
really focused on fathers.
They now get at Berkeley a
semester off from teaching
if they are at least a halftime caretaker.
And mothers get two semesters
off and stop the clock
and the really good part is
men are really taking it up
and we're really seeing
fathers participating
in child raising in a way
that we haven't before.
And this is happening at
other universities as well.
It's the only way, ultimately,
our first feminist.
Well, the early feminist days
in the 1970s the belief was
as long as you'd got women out
in the workplace, et cetera,
the home would take care of itself
and equality would simply happen.
But it didn't happen and
it wasn't just because,
I think men increasingly want more time
with their babies, even,
childcare for sure.
But the workplace did
not make it possible.
Now even if the workplace
makes it possible
they have to get over the cultural issues
of men are the breadwinners
and women are the nurturers.
Those are still very strong and in place
although you probably know that
35% of all American families
are headed by single women breadwinners.
And of those that are married,
women bring in 40% of the income.
So the breadwinner issue
is not what it used to be
by any means, in fact I think
there isn't any clear division
between mothers and fathers
in terms of bringing things
into the household, but the
culture still supports that
to some extent, so that's a real barrier
and one of the things we've
really tried to work on
'cause unless you have the
father playing the game
the mothers won't either.
- So in a way, what the data tells you
is that the way
the family is structured is not conducive
for achieving equality for women
and that one has to tinker
with the family structure,
change the culture of the family structure
so that men share more
equally in the burdens
of household work, taking
care of the children,
daycare and so on.
- Right.
But it really all begins
with structural changes
in the institutions because
men don't have the opportunity
to stay at home unless they're given
some sort of parental leave
or incentives to do so
nor do women, so you have
to have the workplace change
for both men and women and
then the home will reflect that
or could reflect that if
the culture worked at it
strongly enough, and as I
said, I feel some good things
happening here at Berkeley particularly
'cause the percentage of men talking
this active service modified duty
to help with childbirth and
babies has really grown.
And the percentage of,
the number of babies born
to assistant professor women
has doubled since 2003 and
has gone up 60% for men.
So we're in a baby boom. (laughs)
It's embracing the idea of parenthood.
Now this is not a fix and the fix
is not going to be simple or easy,
but I think there is a realization
that it's not gonna work unless
fathers participate as well.
And the fathers actually like it.
All the opinion polls
you see it, they all say
I wish I could do more, it
doesn't make it easy at work.
I'm teased if I do it or I'm
not going to get promoted.
There's discrimination against me
for being the mother,
playing the mommy role
and that's still not culturally accepted.
- And previously before
you institute these changes
when you looked at the
data, men were not suffering
in the way that women were.
Women were essentially
opting out of the system
in order to be the caretaker at home
and to take the time to have children
whereas the men continued to
go on their merry way in a way.
- Yes, and in fact
married men with children
are the most successful, not
just in the university world,
but across the board partly because
they don't have as much
responsibility at home,
but also partly because I
think there's the attitude,
for instance in science
that if a man has a child
then he's really serious.
This will really hold
him down 'cause he has,
you know, responsibilities,
makes him more responsible.
Woman has a child, well,
bye-bye, she's left science,
she has other priorities,
she's not going to be
a responsible scientist,
so it's a negative image
for the woman and a
positive image for the man.
That's only part of it of course.
The structural issues
are important as well.
So it's a combination, but the
structure has to change first
in order to make it
possible for the culture
to promote fathers to
spend more time at home.
- And how hard is that
politically to do actually?
- Well it becomes, the good part
about any kind of cultural change.
Nothing happens, or just
institutional change,
and then all of a sudden
it happens quickly
because it gets competitive.
We named our project
the UC Competitive Edge
and the idea is that we were gonna have
family-friendly policies
so we would get the best
and the brightest and actually
it has worked to some extent
and all the other universities now
have to get on the
bandwagon, so the competition
has kinda changed, used
to be that if you went
to an interview you'd never mentioned
if you had children or
family, it was a no-no.
Now often people will say.
And we have this great
family-friendly policy.
They'll bring it up themselves.
It's really a real sea-change in terms
of how people look at those policies
and think of it as an
asset rather than something
they're going to avoid talking to.
Most these research
universities now have someone
whose main position is to
help families when they arrive
to find jobs and to find schools
and also to help women
through these issues
if they are a faculty.
Less attention paid to
postdocs and graduate students,
which is something I'm still
writing about, caring about.
- Another structure that you identified
as this data began pouring out
was the structure of tenure
basically.
- Yes.
- And as I understand it,
the problem here is that
the child-bearing years
for women coincide,
namely 30 to 40 coincide,
especially in the sciences
with what is perceived
to be the creative period
when careers take off and
research piles up basically
to then justify tenure.
Talk a little about that.
- Well I call those years
the make or break decade.
And it's not just for scientists
or even just for university professors.
In all the professions
that's usually the time,
if you're in business or if
you're in law or medicine.
By the time you're 40 you
have to have basically
firmly pinned down your
career and your place in it
and everything does pretty
much happen during that decade.
You finish your training,
you begin your job,
you do whatever, the
academic world is tougher
because it's intense, it's up or out.
You really don't have any wiggle room.
And you have those six
years, whatever it is,
five or six years to get to tenure
and they're gonna be probably
the most intense years
of your career because
much is expected of you
and plus teaching all new courses.
I mean, it's a very tough time
for all new assistant professors.
And even places that didn't really require
too many publications now require them.
So it's a hotbed, and
because in the academic world
it takes longer and longer to get that PhD
for many different reasons, but you often
don't get a PhD until you're
33, 34, or your postdoc
'cause scientists finish
early but take a while,
so you're really brushing onto
40 by the time you get tenure
it's 40 plus, so women
are likely to kind of wait
if they're going to get tenure or think,
I just can't do this, or have that child
at the most busy time and
can't make the real push
to get tenure and drop out then.
So it's a really difficult problem.
It's more intense in the sciences perhaps
because sciences are so competitive
and their belief is that
if you leave the lab
for 20 minutes practically
you've lost the game.
There is this notion that it's a race
and if you go to the race at anytime
you won't be able to get back in.
But you see it across the board.
So the idea that somehow
your career is over
if you haven't made it by 40
really needs to be changed
in terms of how we look at the,
'cause you're going to have
another, probably 40 years
or 30 years of work in your career
and if you miss the boat
during that period of time
there haven't been many second chances.
So second chances is another thing
that I've really promoted.
I can't say that I had much luck here
at the university system,
when you're out you're out,
but in the science world,
'cause I also deal with NSF
and NASA, the idea of reentry postdocs
is getting some traction, so I'm hoping
that the reentry postdoc,
which would be good
for all kinds of fields actually,
and certainly good in the academic world.
- So the idea is that you could
drop out, but then drop in.
- Drop in again once you had,
and I think for most people, at any rate,
it's the first three or four years
that are the most intense
in terms of child raising.
It doesn't mean that
children don't need attention
all the time but they have
spread out into a larger group.
They don't really want
just mommy all the time.
Or they want to have a
structure outside the home
and they do, they're in preschool,
they're wherever they are
so you're less essential
in terms of the time factor
that goes into it, and
also just less in terms
of the physical factor, they're
no longer attached to you
literally in the same way,
breastfeeding or whatever.
So it is quite reasonable for many women
after two or three years if
they take that long to come back
and men as well, I mean,
or for any family event.
It's not just childbirth,
we have family events
throughout our lives, often unpredictable.
It can be just an illness.
It can be your spouse's illness.
Could be your mother or father's illness
that take you out of the workplace.
Much easier later in life
because if you have tenure
or security of employment of some kind
you can take that time and
they can't do anything.
They can't fire you for it, basically.
- So the argument opposed to
making life for women easier
who want to have children is what?
Is it that, well, this is the way we do it
and this is the way we've always done it?
Or is it, well this is
the most creative time
in a scientist's life and if
we don't get that creativity
out of them in this period
then it won't happen?
What's going on here?
- Well science is, as I say,
is more likely to think this way.
I think law or English
literature or any other field
could understand the value of
coming back after three years
and not having lost your mind, literally.
But in science there
seems to be this belief
that you can't think like a scientist.
I think what's going on here
is just partly a reflection
of the competitiveness the
grant world has gotten into.
But what the granting
agencies are doing now
is discounting the resume gap.
In other words, looking
at your grant applications
and thinking, if you explain
that there was childbirth
involved here then it's a different view
that they'll take with it,
which is a very good thing.
The reentry postdoc.
I mean, there are many things
you can do to rethink a system
so it doesn't have the
same punishing effect
just in this one period of
time because these scientists
have trained for a long
time and a huge investment
has been made in them, it takes a least,
I think a half a million
dollars to put someone
through a PhD and then more
for a postdoc, et cetera.
And this lost investment
as well as lost brains
and it's a foolish kind
of economic analysis.
So this is kind of the message
that I'm trying to get across
and actually seems to
be working pretty well
that we have to look at this differently.
It may be that people do, or some people
do their most productive work up to 30,
but that doesn't mean that all
scientists do that, either.
I'm sure many scientists do wonderful work
in their forties as well and fifties.
And again, a highly trained
mind should not be let go,
and that is what's happening too often.
- One of the issues that keeps coming up
is the change in the status of women
as related to the broader
changes in society.
And so you pointed out earlier
that as there was greater
and greater inequality
that the woman's salary
was needed in the home to keep
the family fiscally sound.
Now in addition another change
that's going quite clear
relates to what you call the second tier.
So given the situation
that was in existence,
women, if they didn't drop
out, you say they dropped down
to second tier positions,
adjuncts, part-time lecturers
and so on, talk a little about that
because that was a benefit
to the system as a whole,
but not necessarily to women.
- Yes.
The fastest growing sector of academia
is the second tier, the
part-time and adjunct.
The percentage of tenure-track
faculty has gone down
from something like 58% to
37% over a period of 20 years.
And that's largely because the model
is use more adjuncts, use more
part-time, and it's largely
been disproportionately
women with children.
There's now a labor
force that is, I suppose,
kind of stuck and will take those jobs
even though they're incredibly underpaid,
under-benefited, marginalized, et cetera.
So we're kind of raising
the second tier in academia
and making it a whole lot more worse.
Well not worse, whole lot worse
by reducing the number
of tenure-track slots.
It's a different model for academia.
I won't even, I probably shouldn't talk
about what's happening
at UC, but nevermind.
We're going to use it, but
in the state universities
there are far more faculty
teaching undergraduate courses
who are not tenure-track
than there are tenure-track.
In the university it is has not had that
partly because we have
lot of graduate students
who help out who have had
a pretty good faculty ratio
that's reducing and reducing and reducing.
And now the classes are
being taught more frequently
by adjuncts or lecturers, et cetera.
In professional schools the adjuncts
have always had strong role
like in law or public health
because it is a professional school,
so the training on the
ground is quite useful.
But now you're seeing it in
many other fields as well.
I think that's very bad for academia.
A lot of women will say
that it's good for mothers
'cause then you don't have all
that pressure to get tenure,
but it's bad for academia
'cause it just dilutes
the equality of works so much
you don't have the possibility
of innovation and free
thinking that you have
with the tenure system therefore
you're not going to have
the kind of innovative knowledge
and culture contributions
that you have now with the tenure system.
And eventually, probably
sooner rather than later,
the best and the brightest
will not want to get PhDs.
They'll consider this, particularly
if there are very few jobs
even for men as well as women.
There's just no place to go.
I fear that that is happening,
so I really promote the tenure system
even though some people say
it works negatively for women
because I think if you had a
different kind of tenure system
and in fact one of our
reforms was to put into place
a part-time pre-tenure as
well as post-tenure track.
So you actually can in the
UC system now go for 10 years
in a part-time position and still
come up for tenure after 10 years.
- Two important tools that
you identify in your work
as graduate dean and now
in the work you're doing
to promote these ideas is on the one hand
the role of the law, the legal system.
And you reference Title IX here,
which guarantees these rights.
But then the other is getting
the word out, basically,
that people should know their rights
and seek to realize them.
- Yes I just actually today
I think finished a law review
article on just this topic
because almost no one knows.
Whenever I lecture to
other universities I say,
how many of you knew that
pregnancy discrimination
is part of Title IX?
Huh, it is?
So it's unknown, and Obama administration
has put a very big drive
on Title IX compliance
because not just pregnancy discrimination
but sexual harassment
and other aspects of it
have not been that well
followed or complied with.
And as part of this, he
doesn't mention this,
but NASA guidelines do.
Pregnancy discrimination is a strong part.
And that's particularly important
for the kinds of things
that I'm concerned about
because you have these
graduate students and postdocs
who do not generally get
protection from FMLA or Title VII
because they're often considered trainees
rather then employees, so
they don't get any kind
of legal protection and this will give,
Title IX will give them
the same kind of protection
they would get under
Title VII or under FMLA.
It also means that if they
have to drop out of a course
or a class that they
have the right to go back
and regain their status so
they don't just lose momentum
and fail to graduate or fail to finish
on the project that they're on, et cetera.
It gives them a lot of
protecting in hiring
and at all kinds of ways that
they're just not aware of
so that in general students and certainly
you can understand this are very reluctant
to complain about anything
because these are the professors
and their livelihood, but
if you have a strong system
in place where people know
that they have the right,
they don't have to complain
directly to the professor.
They can go to the Title IX officer.
It can be done anonymously,
it will be checked out
and then of course if they
don't get satisfaction
they have the right to sue as well.
That will often guilt a
university into action
in terms of complying or
doing more in this line.
I do think this is a very fruitful way
because it would change the culture,
particularly for graduate
students and postdocs
and I think it would
help everyone to know it
who's employed on it within
educational institution
that receives any federal money
that they have a lot of rights
they're probably not aware of
more than just workplace rights.
There are all these rights
about being accepted
into educational programs, not
being kicked out, et cetera.
Really a rich database
which have been not known
and not complied with, but I think
that is going to be changing,
so I'm hopeful about this.
Another new frontier. (laughs)
- What is the responsibility
of the individual woman student
or the young professional?
What is it that they can do for themselves
beyond the change in structure,
beyond the law, beyond the
dissemination of information?
- Well first of all, they
should know their rights.
To fully use the kinds of tools they have
and to know the workplace
policies that exist
and to push for them, that.
But aside from that I think
you're probably talking
about the lean in issue. (laughs)
- Right.
- Well I do think,
it's not totally black and white.
She clearly doesn't talk enough
about institutional change
or about about family, et
cetera, 'cause that is,
at least our research shows
clearly the major reason
why women drop out, but it is true
that women often don't negotiate well.
They don't ask for enough,
they are perhaps more reluctant
in some cases, to some
extent it's density as well.
When I was first dean, I was
the first woman graduate dean.
I was the only woman dean on
campus for a couple of years.
And it is a little intimidating
to be on the cabinet
and everyone is not a
woman and you have to act
in a different way.
You learn how to talk lowly
and slowly and wait and pause.
Not to speak too much, but to be sure
that you reference
someone else with the hope
that they might actually
reference you sometime,
which rarely happens to women,
and then to always have a lot of data.
So I'd come in armed with
PowerPoints. (laughs)
And obviously that's not my background.
I'm not a statistician but the
only way you make your points
is to sort of not so
much do it like the guys,
but to be serious and to show
that you're a serious person.
That got easier as more women became deans
and their voices were
different kinds of voices
and it was just, with
density things do improve.
And as you know, women
are not always so good
about helping other women,
particularly the older school.
I guess I am the older
school, but nonetheless,
in my day the older school wasn't
because you know, they'd
made their sacrifices
and they got here by
whatever means, et cetera.
Or they chose not to have children
and why should they do your work for them?
So this is not necessarily a girls' club
that help each other,
although I have to say
at this university when
I first came the AAW,
which is the faculty women
association was wonderful.
They had everyone be a kind of mentor
from a different department
and they really did help
the young assistant
professors 'cause they'd had
a terrible time getting
tenure in previous years.
A couple of lawsuits helped and
the mentoring helped as well
so they can be very helpful.
As I say, the density helps,
also the issue of service,
and there's been some research on it.
Not ours, but others that
even women who get tenure
often kind of slog out
as associate professors
and their pay shows the kind
of sloped pace they're on
'cause that cumulatively
means they get paid less
toward the end of their career.
And one of the major reasons,
according to this research,
was that they're always
asked to do more service
then are men, and maybe
they're less likely to say no,
I don't know, but women
do more service overall
generally speaking than men do,
at least according to this research,
which is not something
I've researched against.
- Bottom line is that
we have to achieve this
complete and real access for women
because they can bring their
creativity, their intelligence
and maybe a different set of values
as we look at the array of
policy issues that we confront.
- Yes, I mean, this is
a very disputed area
whether women really do have
different leadership qualities
et cetera, but I think it's fairly clear
that they're more cooperative
in terms of their style.
And they're less likely
to blow up. (laughs)
At least the women I know, I don't know.
It's not necessarily
because they're women.
It's because they're also
managing children and family
and a dozen other things
that they get to be.
I would actually rather hire
a mother of three children
who are perhaps in school by this time
than almost anyone else 'cause
they just get things done.
They don't waste time,
there's no doubt about it.
They've got a task and
they'll get it done.
So I think those qualities are
very good in women as well,
whether they have children
or not I think they're good.
So I haven't written on
this or examined this
but just observationally
women do make more cooperative
leaders and are less likely
to fly off the handle and
do rash things. (laughs)
You know, that doesn't mean
that they're better leaders
than men, they just
have a different style.
- Looking back at your career,
I'm curious how you would
evaluate the interplay
between political
movements, the legal system
and the changes that
occur, but then essentially
the power that comes with
administrative positions
to actually try to make change.
We touch on all three
of these in your career
and it seems like it takes all of them
and not one or the other is enough.
- Well, there are individuals
who do wonderful things
whether they've had a background
in this nature or whatever.
The issue with
administration is interesting
because I'm doing this work now,
which is largely policy
work, our research is.
And it has a conclusion in policy
otherwise I wouldn't
find it that interesting
just to be another publication
is not that interesting to me
but it's not the kind of
work for which you get tenure
or climb the ladder
and I didn't do policy
work for many years.
I wrote A History of
Child Custody in America.
I wrote a lot of law reviews.
I did things that were interesting to me,
but were not gonna change the world
because I wasn't in a position to
and it's not what you do as a professor.
You want to do things that are scholarly
and you're rated only on your
contribution to scholarship,
not on changing the world, so
when you're an administrator
you have more power to change the world
and if you take off your,
I must get tenure hat
then you really can use research, I think,
in a positive way, but
not that many faculty can.
And the faculty on this
campus have such brilliance
among them it's always wonderful
when someone makes use of
their work to change the world
'cause rarely are they
in a position to do it.
'Cause you know, outside of politics
where you are in a position
and you're encouraged,
that's why you're
elected, to change things.
I don't think university administrators
are elected or appointed
to change things. (laughs)
so it's something you take on if you,
maybe the president is or the chancellor
but others are meant to kind
of run the ship of state.
But some make wonderful changes, too.
- But by bringing
information to the agenda
you can make some change.
- Yes, exactly.
Unique information, 'cause if
I had that unique information
and was not a high-level administrator
it would be much harder to get
any policy results from it.
So those positions are
very important for that.
- If students were to watch this video
and your reflections on your own career,
what advice would you give
them in terms of preparing
for the future?
- Well, just don't give up your dreams.
It may not happen exactly how you think.
I think we should actually
have a high school class
called life 101 in which
they do a life script.
I mean, they can review it
every five years or whatever,
but to have a sort of a long-range idea
of how you would like your life to unfold
and check in on it and not give up on it
because you're gonna be waylaid.
So take second changes when they come.
I've had several second chances in my life
which have allowed me to be here,
have allowed me to do a
number of different things,
and you have to just grab them
when they come along your way
because I think almost
everyone gets a variety
of opportunities, at least
in this country they do
and they pick and choose
some or the others.
The other advice I give to women,
at least in this book I did,
don't marry a jerk. (laugh)
You know, all the women that
we interviewed for this book
who were very successful
like Dianne Feinstein
or corporate heads or women
who had really had it all,
more or less, they almost
all attributed their success
to their partner, not because he had done
half the diaper changing or whatever,
but the partner was totally supportive
economically and otherwise
and always took their career
as seriously as his own.
And that's really the
criteria for an equal marriage
and it allows women as well
as men to flourish in it.
If it meant that he'd
have to make the move,
and among academics that's often the case.
You have a dual career
family and unfortunately
it's a two-body problem
and it's more often
that the man's body gets
the choice than the women's,
those kinds of decisions
which are very hard
and academia's particularly tough on them
because you're only
limited to a number of jobs
in certain geographical.
But actually make sure
that the partner you have
is not holding you down,
they're pushing you forward.
- Well, on that note Mary
Ann I want to thank you,
but let me show your book
one more time to our audience
'cause it's a very succinct manual
for the problems that
we've been talking about.
So thank you again for--
- Thank you Harry.
I enjoyed it very much.
- For being on our program.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(upbeat electronic music)